the queen mother's Crown is set with 2
800 diamonds but pride of place in the
center sits the dazzling Kohinoor or
mountain of light one of the largest and
most controversial in existence
for centuries the Kohinoor was a spoil
of Conquest but in 1849 dilip Singh the
Maharaja of the vastly wealthy Punjab
region of India was forced by British
colonialists to give it up and all his
lands at just 10 years old says
historian Anita Anand co-author of
kohidur the history of the world's most
infamous Diamond why do you think for so
many South Asians the Kohinoor has
become this Burning symbol of the pain
of colonialism the way when it came here
it didn't look the way it does now it
was twice the size despite all the
advice of the contrary Prince Albert
queen Queen Victoria's husband decides
to recut it to make it behave better to
make it more acceptable to the British
for Indians it's such a neat metaphor
for the Raj you know that it changed a
people it changed a place it diminished
a place
in February Buckingham Palace announced
Camilla the queen consort would wear a
modified version of the Queen Mary Crown
at King Charles's coronation without the
Kohinoor why does Britain why does the
Royal Family hold on to it there have
been representations from Afghanistan
they've been representations from Iran
there have been multiple requests for it
back from India so the British always
say okay you know all right we can't
give it back because we don't know who
to give it to
in the coronation's build-up the diamond
and who it belongs to has become a
lightning rod of debate in Britain
and colonizer is
history and actually it's dehumanizing
Indians around the world because of the
history
even out of sight the Kohinoor remains a
potent symbol not only of the British
Empire and its dark legacies but of the
scrutiny that passed now faces something
Britain's new king and queen consort
will have to navigate carefully do you
have one extreme saying why are you
talking about this all Empires take
treasure it's just the by virtue of
colonialism that's what it's there for
stop talking about it stop making us
feel bad stop dredging up the past and
on the other side you have equally sort
of opposing and hot give it all back
send it all back doesn't belong to you
say sorry move on and in the middle
which is where I happen to live
can we just talk about it can we just
say where it came from can we just talk
about it honestly without Conjuring sort
of mythologies about things being
grateful gifts India's Time CBS News
London